[Music]
we are getting more Wonderwoman
three words for you Brooke gal gadot
rocks girl power
absolutely now the movie is the
phenomenon of the summer and et has now
confirmed there will be a Wonder Woman
sequel stay here I'll go ahead the
sequel is set to take place between 1917
and 2017 which likely means once again
gal will have seen set during World War
one there's no timetable for the next
film so far Wonder Woman has earned an
estimated five hundred seventy eight
million dollars worldwide making Gao a
global superstar with her own tape on
the feminist message of the film
feminism is not about women against men
or they hate men or they burn their bras
and have armpits hair it's not about
that it's it's about we can wear
whatever we want to wear we can do
whatever wanted to you know it's all
about that we know director patty
Jenkins is working on the script for the
sequel but she hasn't said it she'll
direct it but she's told me she loves
working with gap she is like a special
gift to this world to play that role
for me when I just started being an
actress I always said that I want to
show this other side of women little did
I know that I would land it's part
I hope we're starting a trend here but
it's amazing
[Music]
you